let's continue our trip across the
country and the world I guess I would
say on the phones with our next caller
from the 71 for area code caller from
seven one four what's your name where
are you calling from and what's your
question today
hey I'm Laura I'm in Orange County
California my question is with Democrats
losing so many seats in local and state
government over the past eight or ten
years what percentage of that is because
of gerrymandering and what percentage of
that is just maybe laziness on the part
of the Democrats or them not being
motivated enough to go first eight in
midterm election yeah well listen it's
there's no I mean I could if I I'm not
going to get to 54% is because of
gerrymandering and 46 because of
laziness but you're pointing out two
pretty serious issues that are going on
right now one as we spoke about at
length with big bill o Goolsbee a couple
of months ago and as we explored in
detail in our deep dive video into
gerrymandering right now there are two
elements that are significantly favoring
Republicans when it comes to the
electoral map one is straight-up
gerrymandering through the sketchy
drawing of congressional districts
that's not the only issue as bill
Oglesby told us the fact that urban
centers are more liberal and rural areas
are more conservative that also actually
favors conservatives in total so that's
a big part of what's going on but you're
pointing out the other issue of what's
going on Laura which is that even below
the state Senate and state Rep level
even if you look at like City Council's
I mean at many many different layers
Republicans have just out organized
progressives and the reasons why can be
debated that's probably a broader
conversation not not for us but the
amount of money that the right is
putting into training young candidates
to come out of college and run for City
Council or whatever young mayors etc
state Rep State Center
there's the left is being out organized
and these both of issues Pat that Laura
is pointing out irrelevant here and just
seems when there was those prominent
races like when Mitch McConnell had a
challenger in Alison lundergan Grimes
you know she refused to support the
president when we had a Democratic
president or you had John Asif in
Georgia who ran on you know the deficit
reduction and gave a concession speech
with a humility banner behind him yeah I
mean that's not strong enough to rally
people to support you yeah
and you know this isn't to say Laura
that the positions of many of these
candidates or of any particular
individual is wrong but there's both
systemic and sort of uh I don't know
that I want to call the motivation but
yeah it there's been a lack of decision
made by the left to fund the lower
levels of elected office the way that
Republicans have and you know it's very
low energy yeah well thank you for
answering my question all right Laura
thanks so much to go great to hear from
you